brilliance from the young man respect  from the coaches  [Applause]  [Music]  and this series is over the first round  is over the home team finally gets a win  the clippers advance  the stoic superstar kawhi leonard 28  points 10 rebounds nine assists  and brilliant defense  and as you said earlier jeff it's tough  here you watch a guy like luka doncic  play the way he played and his season's  over  just it's so brutally hard to try to win  a playoff series particularly in the  western conference  [Applause]  these four five matchups are incredible  and  they're difficult and challenging  [Music]  and the clippers could easily win the  whole thing  they're that good that's got to be  mentality  [Music]